Back in the 1970s, the Atlanta Journal Newspaper several times a week for years published this column called the Georgia Rambler. Charles Salter wrote the column. Basically he would get up in the morning, say goodbye to his wife, Sally, get in his car, and head out on the road to some small town, sometimes without much of a plan at all, not even sure where he's going to end up.
在20世纪70年代，亚特兰大《亚特兰大新闻报》多年来每周数次刊登一个名为“乔治亚漫游者”的专栏。查尔斯·索尔特是该专栏的作者。基本上，他每天早上起床，跟妻子萨莉告别，坐上他的车，前往某个小镇，有时根本没有什么计划，甚至不知道自己最终会到哪里。
I would look at a Georgia highway map. And Sally would say, honey, where are you going this morning? And I said, I think I'll go east. And I'd would go over to a town 50, 80, 100 miles from Atlanta, and I would see the county agent, or the cafe where the guys and gals would gather to drink coffee and talk. And I'd say you all have probably read Rita's Digest. For a long term they had an article called The Most Unforgettable Person I Ever Met. Well who in your town, who's the most unforgettable person you ever met? Who would you talk about if he were at a convention 1,000 miles away. I wish you fellas could known so and so back home.
我会看一张乔治亚州公路地图。萨莉会问，亲爱的，你今天早上要去哪儿？我说，我想去东边。我会去距离亚特兰大50、80或100英里外的一个城镇，我会见当地的农业推广员，或者去那些男男女女聚在一起喝咖啡聊天的小餐馆。我会问，你们大概都读过《读者文摘》吧。他们长期以来有个专栏叫《我所见过最难忘的人》。那么在你们镇上，谁是你见过最难忘的人？如果他在1000英里外的某个会议上，你会谈论谁？我真希望你们这些伙计能认识家乡的某某人。
I was seeking good stories from ordinary folks.
我当时在寻找普通民众的好故事。
There was the 55-year-old man who never wore shoes, and the pharmacist who discovered in an old ledger there seemed to be a recipe for Coca-Cola. And the country father of five who told the Georgia Rambler that when he goes to the sales barn to buy a small calf, "I call it buying me a lawn mower. When the grass dies down thanks to the calf, I kill my lawnmower and eat it".
比如那个从不穿鞋的55岁男人，还有那个在旧账本里发现好像有可口可乐配方的药剂师。还有那个有五个孩子的乡下父亲，他告诉“乔治亚漫游者”，当他去牲口集市买小牛时，“我管这叫买割草机。当小牛把草吃光后，我就杀掉我的割草机并吃掉它。”
There's Pete Ware, Justice of the Peace in Troup County, who said that he did 40% of his weddings after midnight, including shotgun weddings. Though he complained to the Georgia Rambler that people these days are too lazy to bring shotguns to their shotgun weddings.
还有特鲁普县的太平绅士皮特·韦尔，他说他在午夜后处理了40%的婚礼，包括“枪口下的婚礼”。尽管他向“乔治亚漫游者”抱怨，现在的人太懒了，甚至懒得带猎枪参加他们的“枪口下的婚礼”。
And also was lucky enough to hear about haunted houses.
而且我还很幸运地听到了关于闹鬼房子的故事。
Yeah, I've been reading your columns and it seems like a there's a lot of haunted houses in Georgia.
是啊，我一直在读你的专栏，看起来乔治亚州有很多闹鬼的房子。
Yes, and I had a lot a funny interviewing a woman who was in the Marine Corps with Lee Harvey Oswald. And down in [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
是的，我采访一位曾经与李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德一起在海军陆战队服役的女性时，觉得非常有趣。在[听不清]……
I sort of forgot he was trained as a Marine.
我倒是忘了他也曾受训成为一名海军陆战队员。
Yes. And his nickname was the creep. And they were on the rifle range one day, and the devil winds were blowing out of the desert. I forget the word for it, the Spanish word, and he was still shooting while the others were smoking cigarettes and drinking coffee. Because they couldn't shoot accurately with the wind blowing from the side. And he kept hitting the bull's eye.
是的。他的绰号叫“怪胎”。有一天他们在射击场，沙漠里刮着魔鬼风。我忘了那个词怎么说了，是西班牙语，当其他人在抽烟喝咖啡时，他还在射击。因为侧风太大，其他人无法精准射击。而他却一直命中靶心。
OK, full disclosure, Charles' son Chuck is married one of the producers of our radio show, Lisa Pollak, which is how we heard about the Georgia Rambler. And when all of us here at our radio show-- you're listening to This American Life by the way from WBEZ Chicago disturbed by Public Radio international-- when all of us heard about the Georgia Rambler, and this idea that you would get out of the city and just drive into some small town at random, walk around, and talk to people until you find a story, and get all these people from these towns with just a couple hundred a couple thousand people all over Georgia talking about life where they live, it just seemed like a really fun thing to try.
好吧，披露一下，查尔斯的儿子查克娶了我们广播节目的制片人之一丽莎·波拉克，我们就是这样听说“乔治亚漫游者”的。当我们要在这里做广播节目时——顺便说一下，你正在收听的是由WBEZ芝加哥制作、国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》——当听到“乔治亚漫游者”以及那种走出城市，随机开车去某个小镇，四处走走，与人交谈直到找到故事的想法时，听到这些来自乔治亚州各地的、只有几百或几千人口的小镇居民讲述他们生活的地方，这听起来是一件非常有趣的事情，值得一试。
So these last few weeks, nine of us flew down in Georgia. It was producers of our radio show plus comedian and author Eugene Mirman, and we brought the son of the Georgia Rambler, Chuck. There are a 159 counties in Georgia. We picked nine counties from a hat. We used an Atlanta Braves baseball cap for that. Each of us went to a different county, spend just a day of two, and we ended up with so many stories that we can't come close to fitting them all into one show. Though we can fit seven, which we bring you today.
所以在过去的几周里，我们九个人飞到了乔治亚州。其中包括我们广播节目的制片人、喜剧演员兼作家尤金·米尔曼，我们还带上了“乔治亚漫游者”的儿子查克。乔治亚州有159个县。我们用帽子抽签选出了九个县。我们为此用了一顶亚特兰大勇士队的棒球帽。我们每个人去了不同的县，只待了一两天，结果我们得到了太多的故事，根本没法塞进一期节目里。虽然我们可以选出七个，今天就带给你们。
And we'll just kick things off here. We'll start things off with Dave Kestenbaum, who's usually a correspondent for NPR's Planet Money, who we took off the economics beat and sent to Georgia to look for some story or person that is unforgettable.
我们先从这里开始。我们从戴夫·克斯坦鲍姆开始，他通常是美国国家公共电台（NPR）《星球经济》的记者，我们让他暂时放下经济新闻，派他去乔治亚州寻找一个难忘的故事或人物。
And Dave, you went to Meriwether County, right near the western border of the state.
戴夫，你去了梅里韦瑟县，就在该州的西侧边界，对吧？
Yes, and the people of Meriwether County were extremely friendly. They were happy to give directions or recommend a place for lunch. But they were completely at a loss when I asked the one question that mattered. Who is the most unforgettable person in town? "Unforgettable", people would say, "In this town"? Someone showed me a phone book. It was thinner than your finger. The Rs, Ss, and Ts were all on the same page.
是的，梅里韦瑟县的人们非常友好。他们很乐意指路或推荐午餐地点。但当我问出那个最关键的问题时，他们完全不知所措。谁是镇上最难忘的人？“难忘？”人们会说，“在这个镇上？”有人给我看了电话簿。它比你的手指还薄。R、S和T都在同一页上。
There was one person who came up over and over again, lots of people mentioned his name. The gentleman in question is dead. Though I suppose if people talk about you after you die, that's pretty much the definition of unforgettable. People said he helped the poor, he was a good, good man, and everyone knew him by his initials,
有一个人被反复提到，很多人都提到了他的名字。这位先生已经去世了。不过我想，如果人们在你死后还会谈论你，这几乎就是“难忘”的定义了。人们说他帮助穷人，是个非常好的人，大家都用他的名字缩写来称呼他……
My friends and neighbors--
我的朋友们和邻居们……
FDR.
FDR（富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福）。
--11 years ago, I came to live at Warm Springs for the first time.
……11年前，我第一次来到温泉区居住。
Franklin Delano Roosevelt came to Warm Springs, Georgia 41 times. Yes, people count. He set up a polio treatment center here. The locals say proudly, this was a place he could relax. He would get a fiddle player to come and play at night. But Sylvia Bishop Wright, she lives in an area called the Cove, she told me FDR liked to do something else, something you don't read in the history books.
富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福曾41次来到乔治亚州的温泉区。是的，人们都记着呢。他在这里建立了一个小儿麻痹症治疗中心。当地人自豪地说，这是一个他可以放松的地方。他会让小提琴手晚上来演奏。但住在被称为“海湾”地区的西尔维娅·毕肖普·赖特告诉我，FDR还喜欢做另一件事，那是你在历史书中读不到的。
When Roosevelt was coming down here, he especially liked the moonshine in the Cove.
罗斯福来这里时，他特别喜欢“海湾”地区的私酿威士忌。
Roosevelt liked Moonshine?
罗斯福喜欢私酿威士忌？
They called it stump juice because they'd hide it in the old stumps.
他们管那叫“树桩果汁”，因为他们把它藏在旧树桩里。
In a tree stump?
在树桩里？
In a tree stump. They'd just hide it down there. Am I telling things I shouldn't be telling?
在树桩里。他们就把酒藏在那下面。我是不是说了不该说的话？
I was pretty sure this didn't count. You can't go to some small town in search of someone unforgettable and come back with Franklin Delano Roosevelt, the former President of the United States, someone everyone already knows. But then I thought wait, Roosevelt would have been drinking during prohibition when it was illegal to sell alcohol, illegal the manufacturer it, to transport it, we wrote it into our constitution which FDR swore in his oath of office to preserve, protect, and defend. I got more interested when Sylvia left me a voicemail later that day.
我很确定这不算数。你不能去某个小镇寻找难忘的人，结果带回来的却是富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福，这位美国前总统，一个大家都已经认识的人。但后来我想，等等，罗斯福喝这些酒是在禁酒令时期，当时销售酒精是非法的，制造、运输都是非法的，我们把它写进了宪法，而FDR在就职誓词中发誓要维护、保护和捍卫它。当我那天晚些时候收到西尔维娅的语音留言时，我变得更感兴趣了。
They David, hey. This is Sylvia at the newspaper. And you know how you get to thinking about things. You know when we were talking about the booze, you know the stump juice and all, and about how Roosevelt liked it. But I'm telling you, I don't want anything said about Roosevelt that would be wrong. These folks down here will fight you about Franklin D. Roosevelt.
喂，戴维，你好。我是报社的西尔维娅。你知道你怎么会去想那些事。你知道我们谈论酒的时候，你知道“树桩果汁”之类的，还有罗斯福是怎么喜欢它的。但我告诉你，我不希望关于罗斯福有任何错误的说法。这里的人会为了富兰克林·D·罗斯福跟你拼命的。
Then silence like she'd covered up the mouth piece. There was a second voicemail from her.
接着是一阵沉默，好像她捂住了话筒。她又发来了第二条语音留言。
David, this is Sylvia again. I was interrupted right in the middle of my message. But like I said, these people down here love Franklin D. Roosevelt. You know his little white house is about three miles down the road. And I guess that's why people knew him on such a personal basis because he was such a good man and so friendly. And they loved him as president, absolutely. He came down here before he was president also and made friends with everybody. But I just wanted to make sure nothing bad was said about FDR.
戴维，我是西尔维娅。我的留言被打断了。但正如我所说，这里的人非常爱戴富兰克林·D·罗斯福。你知道他那个小白屋就在三英里外的路上。我想这就是为什么人们对他有那种私下的了解，因为他是个好人，也非常友善。作为总统，他们绝对爱戴他。他当总统前也来过这里，和每个人都成了朋友。我只是想确保没有人说FDR的坏话。
I went to that place that Sylvia mentioned, the little white house where FDR used to stay. He actually died here. The place is a museum now. And I asked about FDR and moonshine. Two guys told me, "Yeah, that's the local legend". But they didn't know if it was true. Clearly this is not a question historians have devoted much effort to answering. It's the 1930s version of did you inhale. Did you, sir, drink moonshine. Well, did you?
我去了西尔维娅提到的那个地方，就是FDR曾经住过的小白屋。他实际上死在这里。现在这里成了博物馆。我问起FDR和私酿威士忌的事。两个人告诉我：“是的，那是当地的传说。”但他们不知道是否属实。显然，历史学家并没有花太多精力去回答这个问题。这简直是1930年代版的“你吸入了吗？”。先生，您喝过私酿威士忌吗？好吧，你喝过吗？
So now I found myself driving on the back roads into the Georgia woods to see if some president drank moonshine. I stopped at a small house this looked like it had definitely been there since FDR died. A tiny Porsche with three people just sitting on it. I waved as I walked up. They waved back. There was an old man, an older woman, and a younger guy, Roland Brown
所以现在我发现自己正开着车穿过乔治亚州树林里的后路，去看看某位总统是否喝过私酿威士忌。我在一个小房子前停下，那房子看起来肯定在FDR去世时就已经在了。一辆微型保时捷，上面坐着三个人。我走过去时挥了挥手。他们也挥手回应。有一个老人、一位年长的妇女和一个年轻人，罗兰·布朗。
This is the cove. This area is where they call the cove.
这就是海湾。这个地区被称为海湾。
I took a breath and asked did FDR come here to get moonshine?
我深吸了一口气，问FDR是不是来这里买私酿威士忌的？
Well I wasn't here. I couldn't tell you about that.
嗯，我当时不在。我可没法告诉你那个。
Is that something you've heard?
这是你听说过的事吗？
Well, I ain't going to tell you that. I don't know. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. You could go over the mountain and talked to Mr. Bunn-Wright's daughter and she might tell you. Mr. Bunn-Wright played the fiddle for him. He lived out here. One of Mr. Bunn-Wright's daughters is the only one left living I think.
嗯，我不会告诉你那个的。我不知道。[听不清的短语]。你可以翻过山去跟邦恩·赖特先生的女儿谈谈，她可能会告诉你。邦恩·赖特先生曾为他拉过小提琴。他住在这里。我想邦恩·赖特先生的女儿中只有一位还健在。
And the woman's name I'm looking for?
我正在找的那位女士的名字是？
Aunt Nee is what we call her, Aunt Nee Newman. I don't even really know what her first name is.
我们叫她尼阿姨，尼·纽曼阿姨。我甚至不知道她的名字叫什么。
I drove over the mountains and found Aunt Nee's house. The doors were locked, no cars. I stood there for a minute knocking, trying all of the doors, but the house with silent. I gave up and drove away.
我翻过山找到了尼阿姨的家。门锁着，没有车。我在那里敲了一会儿门，试了所有的门，但房子里一片寂静。我放弃了，开车离开了。
On the right side of the road, I saw a woman working in a field. What the hell, I thought, I rolled down the window. "Do know someone named Aunt Nee"? "Aunt Nee? Yes", she said. She's my Aunt Nee". The woman pointed back to the house on the hill where I just knocked on the door. "Aunt Nee", she explained "is hard of hearing".
在路右边，我看到一个女人在田里干活。管他呢，我想，我摇下车窗问：“你认识一个叫尼阿姨的人吗？”“尼阿姨？是的，”她说，“她是我的尼阿姨。”那个女人指了指我刚才敲过门的山上的房子。“尼阿姨，”她解释说，“听力不好。”
I might not get her to the door. That white house right up on top of the hill. And she's 90 going on 91. I might have to go up and get her to the door.
我可能没法让她来开门。就是山顶上那座白房子。她90岁了，快91了。我可能得上去让她来开门。
Do you think you could come with me? That would be wonderful.
你觉得你能跟我一起去吗？那太好了。
I'll walk you there.
我陪你走过去。
Thank you.
谢谢。
The woman whose name is Linda Carpenter, took me back to the house that seemed empty. Inside in near darkness in an armchair was Aunt Nee doing some sort of puzzle from a magazine. Aunt Nee's full name is Cornelia Wright Newman. Aunt Nee told me yes, she met President Roosevelt when she was a girl. FDR loved her father's fiddle player. Because her hearing isn't so good, the way the interview would work is I would ask a question in what I thought was a loud voice, and Linda would shout it out even louder.
那个叫琳达·卡彭特的女人带我回到了那间看起来空无一人的房子。屋里昏暗处，一张扶手椅上坐着尼阿姨，正在做某种杂志上的拼图。尼阿姨的全名是科尼利娅·赖特·纽曼。尼阿姨告诉我，是的，她还是个小女孩时就见过罗斯福总统。FDR很喜欢她父亲的小提琴。因为她听力不太好，采访的方式是我用自认为很大的声音提问，然后琳达再大声地喊给她听。
So Sylvia told me that FDR used to come here to the Cove to buy moonshine.
西尔维娅告诉我，FDR以前常来海湾买私酿威士忌。
Did FDR come to the Cove to buy moonshine?
FDR来过海湾买私酿威士忌吗？
To buy moonshine? Yeah he'd come down to Uncle Charlie's old store, Gilbert's store down there. And that's where he met Daddy.
买私酿威士忌？是的，他会来查理叔叔的老杂货店，就是下面的吉尔伯特店。他在那里遇到了我爸爸。
Did he buy moonshine? Did FDR buy moonshine there? Did he buy moonshine in Uncle Charlie's old store? FDR?
他买过私酿威士忌吗？FDR在那里买过私酿威士忌吗？他在查理叔叔的老店买过私酿威士忌吗？FDR？
Yeah, yeah. He was over there one time when he'd come by, he was over there to get his groceries from Uncle Charlie's. And he stopped and he found out where Daddy lived and he'd only played the fiddle. And he'd come on over there.
对，对。他有一次过来的时候就在那儿，他在查理叔叔那儿买杂货。他停下来，发现了爸爸住在哪里，他只拉小提琴。他就过来了。
But he bought moonshine also, moonshine? FDR bought moonshine there?
但他买过私酿威士忌吗，私酿威士忌？FDR在那儿买过私酿威士忌？
I don't know if he did or not. I don't know.
我不知道他买没买。我不知道。
I don't know either. Because I was a little, bitty girl. I don't know if FDR bought moonshine or not.
我也不知道。因为那时我还是个小不点儿。我不知道FDR买没买私酿威士忌。
I don't know either.
我也不知道。
By this point I gave up on the idea of getting an answer. It was only listening back to the recording later that I realized Aunt Nee was only saying she never saw him buy moonshine at that particular store. And later she said this.
到此为止，我放弃了得到答案的想法。只有后来回听录音时，我才意识到尼阿姨只是说她从未见过他在那家特定的店里买酒。但后来她说了这个：
Now he'd come down and got moonshine, I know.
他确实下来弄过私酿威士忌，我知道。
Franklin Roosevelt?
富兰克林·罗斯福？
Roosevelt did. But where he got it, I don't know. But he didn't get it at [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Daddy didn't fool with it. Mama wouldn't allow that.
罗斯福确实弄过。但他在哪儿弄的，我不知道。但他没在[听不清]弄过。爸爸不掺和那个。妈妈不允许那样。
I don't know what Aunt Nee saw or heard that makes her believe FDR drank moonshine. As proof, it's not so satisfying. I did talk with one other person, a local actor who has played the role of FDR and is a bit of an FDR buff.
我不知道尼阿姨看到了或听到了什么，让她相信FDR喝过私酿威士忌。作为证据，这不太令人信服。我确实和另一个人聊过，一个演过FDR角色的当地演员，他还是个FDR迷。
He told me he had heard from people who knew firsthand that yes, FDR drank moonshine. He said a man named Bum Phillips had told him a story about bringing FDR quarts of moonshine then having to hide them when the Baptist preacher stopped by unannounced.
他告诉我，他从亲身经历过的人那里听说，是的，FDR喝过私酿威士忌。他说一个叫巴姆·菲利普斯的人告诉他，他给FDR送过几夸脱私酿威士忌，当浸信会牧师不请自来时，他还得把酒藏起来。
But if you're looking for proof, well there don't seem to be any photographs. If you want to firsthand account, Aunt Nee is one of the last people living who might have seen Roosevelt take a swing.
但如果你要找证据，好吧，似乎没有任何照片。如果你想要亲身经历，尼阿姨是最后几个可能见过罗斯福喝酒的人之一。
The truth is that FDR had a complicated life. Warm Springs was one of the few places where everyone knew he had polio. When he died here, it was not with his wife, but with another woman, Lucy Mercer Rutherford. When we say someone is unforgettable, it doesn't mean we remember everything. It can be nice to forget. If you like the picture FDR drinking moonshine with the locals, go ahead. If you don't, it never happened. nah
事实是，FDR的一生很复杂。温泉区是少数几个大家都知道他患有小儿麻痹症的地方之一。他在这里去世时，陪在他身边的不是他的妻子，而是另一个女人，露西·默瑟·卢瑟福。当我们说某人难忘时，并不意味着我们记得一切。忘记有时也很好。如果你喜欢罗斯福与当地人一起喝私酿威士忌的画面，那就随它去吧。如果你不喜欢，那就当它没发生过。
This is Eugene Mirman. I was sent to Hall County. It's a Sunday night in Gainesville, Georgia. On the advise of the woman at the front desk of the Holiday Inn, we head to Wild Wings to find people to tell us about interesting people to find. We're told it's one of the most fun places in town. Also it's the only place open.
我是尤金·米尔曼。我被派到了霍尔县。在乔治亚州的盖恩斯维尔，这是一个周日晚上。在假日酒店前台那位女士的建议下，我们前往“野翅”餐馆寻找可以告诉我们有趣人物的人。据说是城里最好玩的地方之一，也是唯一营业的地方。
We are the most interesting people in Gainesville. Have you ever seen the show friends? No, you know that show Friends and you know Phoebe off Friends? And she just like world peace, love everybody. That's the way I am.
我们就是盖恩斯维尔最有趣的人。你看过《老友记》吗？不，你知道那部剧《老友记》，还有剧里的菲比吗？她就是追求世界和平，爱每一个人。我就是那样的人。
This is Matt Norris. He's 27, but doesn't look a day over 23. He's there with two friends. All three work at Wild Wings. They're hanging out drinking as it's closing up for the night. Matt's just discovered Friends on DVD with the kind of enthusiasm potential rock stars discover The Velvet Underground. My producer thinks he might be gay. But I think he just likes R.E.M. and wants to be an artist. I'm going to refer to him as Artist Matt, because--
这是马特·诺里斯。他27岁，但看起来不超过23岁。他和两个朋友在那儿。三个人都在“野翅”工作。他们打烊了在闲逛喝酒。马特刚刚带着一种潜在摇滚明星发现地下丝绒乐队般的热情发现了《老友记》的DVD。我的制片人觉得他可能是同性恋，但我认为他只是喜欢R.E.M.乐队，想成为一名艺术家。我管他叫“艺术家马特”，因为——
Wait a second, are all three of you named Matt?
等等，你们三个都叫马特吗？
We're three Matts.
我们是三个马特。
If y'all followed us around at work for like a day, I swear to god you'd laugh your ass off for like three days. Like you have abs.
如果你们像这样跟着我们工作一天，我向上帝发誓，你会笑得肚子疼三天。就像你有腹肌一样。
The other two Matts are Big Matt and Quiet Matt. Big Matt is fun and gregarious. Quiet Matt doesn't say much. Quiet Matt and Big Matt say we just missed the perfect day to hang out with them.
另外两个马特是“大马特”和“安静马特”。大马特风趣且健谈。安静马特不怎么说话。安静马特和大马特说我们错过了跟他们一起闲逛的最完美的一天。
It was the 4th of July. I was the 4th of frickin' July. We were trashed. We closed the restaurant down.
那是7月4日，该死的7月4日。我们烂醉如泥。我们关了餐馆。
closed Wild Wings down and we rented a house boat out on Lake Lanier. When you go to the lake, you go to Cocktail Cove. Cocktail Cove is where all the boats like daisy chain each other together and just have a massive party. And you just walk across with your coolers of beer, and your food and [BLEEP]. And everybody just drinks, and flashes, and has fun. I swam to the boat full of hot chicks like 20 yard, maybe 30 yards away. And everybody was hollering at him and saying this, that, and the other. But they wouldn't acknowledge anything. So what did I do? What did Matt Fry do? Matt Fry jumped off the top of the house and swam over there and got him, and brought them all back.
关了“野翅”餐馆，我们在拉尼尔湖上租了一艘船屋。去湖边时，你会去“鸡尾酒湾”。鸡尾酒湾是所有船只像雏菊链一样连在一起开大型派对的地方。你可以提着装满啤酒和食物的冷却箱走过去……每个人都在喝酒、暴露身体，玩得很开心。我向大约20码，也许30码外的一船辣妹游了过去。每个人都在冲他尖叫，说这个那个的。但她们什么反应都没有。所以我做了什么？马特·弗莱做了什么？马特·弗莱从房顶跳了下去，游过去，把她们都带回来了。
Big Matt Fry is all about solutions, taking action. Quiet Matt was more like a smoking crocodile, floating from place to place to observing.
大马特·弗莱是个解决问题的人，喜欢采取行动。安静马特更像是一只抽着烟的鳄鱼，从一个地方飘到另一个地方观察着。
Be honest, I'm in the water. And I'm just treading and I'm swimming away smoking a cigarette in the water, trying to keep it from getting wet. And I turn around. And there's this chick on a floaty. And I look, and like right in my face she's got them jokers just strung out there. So I'm just sitting there and I'm puffing my cigarette, and I wasn't moving. I was like, I'm going to stay right here.
老实说，我当时在水里。我就在漂着，抽着烟游泳，试图不让烟弄湿。我转过身。有一个妞在浮排上。我看了一眼，她就在我面前……所以我就坐在那儿抽着烟，我没动。我想，我就待在这儿。
The Matt I keep thinking about the most is Artist Matt, because Artist Matt, partially inspired by Friends, wants to move to New York City and follow his dream of becoming a video editor, a totally attainable dream. But he can't for two reasons. One he's afraid he'll become homeless, and doesn't know he could just move back the day he becomes homeless. And two, he's on probation. Actually they all are. Big Matt for several DUIs, Quiet Matt for something to do with weed, and Artist Matt for speeding.
我一直想得最多的还是“艺术家马特”，因为艺术家马特，部分受《老友记》启发，想搬到纽约市，追寻他成为视频剪辑师的梦想，这是一个完全可以实现的梦想。但他不能，原因有两个。一是他害怕变得无家可归，不知道他一旦无家可归随时可以搬回来。二是他在缓刑期间。事实上他们都在缓刑：大马特是因为多次酒驾，安静马特是因为大麻，而艺术家马特是因为超速。
I'm on probation because I got a freaking speeding ticket. It's just a speeding ticket, who gives a crap?
我因为该死的超速罚单而在缓刑。那只是一张超速罚单，谁在乎呢？
Wait, why would you be on probation for a speeding ticket? Is it you're ninth one?
等等，为什么超速罚单会让你被判缓刑？你是第九次了吗？
No. It was my first one. But I was kind of going 40 over.
不是，那是第一次。但我超速了40英里。
Oh, was it a school zone?
哦，是学校区域吗？
No, but it was a deaf child area. But the kid was at school. What the hell did it matter? It was like 2 o'clock. He should have been at school anyway.
不是，但那是失聪儿童区域。但孩子当时在学校。这有什么关系？当时两点钟了。他们早就在学校了。
Assuming that the speed limit was somewhere around 25 miles an hour, it means he was doing 65 or 70 in a residential neighborhood.
假设限速是每小时25英里左右，意味着他在居民区开到了65或70英里。
You know what the funny thing is?
你知道有趣的事是什么吗？
Tell me the funny thing.
告诉我有趣的事。
I had just bought a brand new car. And I had seriously just left the dealership. And I lived in Commerce, and I know you don't know where that's at, but it's like 45 minutes away from here. And I was going down back roads. And I had just pulled out of the dealership in this new car. And it was awesome. I'm looking good. I'm jammin'. I got a new car. I'm going to get some chicks tonight.
我刚买了一辆崭新的车。我真的是刚离开车行。我住在商业区，我知道你不知道那在哪儿，但离这有45分钟路程。我走的是后路。我刚开着这辆新车从车行出来。太棒了。我看起来很帅。我正在狂欢。我有了新车。今晚我要泡妞。
So when the cop pulls me over, I'm not scared or anything. He pulls me over. He gets my license, and registration, and insurance stuff, and I'm still jammin'. I got a new car. Who gives a crap I'm getting pulled over right now. I get out of my car and I'm like looking in the trunk just to see what's going on back there, because I've never looked back there. I just bought this car. This is the first car I had ever bought by myself. I'm checking out the bass sounds. And the officer puts me in handcuffs because he thinks I'm about to like shoot him, or run, or something. . I'm like, what are you talking about? I just bought a car. I'm just freaking excited.
所以当警察把我拦下时，我一点也不害怕。他把我拦下。他拿走了我的驾照、行驶证和保险单，但我还在狂欢。我有一辆新车。谁在乎我现在被警察拦下了。我下车，像是在后备箱看里面有什么，因为我从来没看过。这是我自己买的第一辆车。我在测试低音效果。警察给我戴上手铐，因为他以为我要开枪，或者逃跑，或者什么。我说，你在说什么？我刚买了一辆车。我只是太兴奋了。
When you explain that to the policeman, was he like, oh yeah, you're just the classic guy who bought a car and is checking it out?
当你向警察解释时，他有没有说，哦，你是那种刚买了车就到处乱看的经典人物？
Hell no, hell no, not at all. Good lord, no. He was pissed. It was bad.
见鬼不，绝对没有。老天爷，根本没有。他被激怒了。那很糟糕。
What kind of a person, in the middle of being pulled over by a cop, decides to just check out the trunk of their new car? That's a terrible idea. But Artist Matt is an artist. He's Phoebe from Friends. He doesn't realize that success is right at hand. He could move an hour and a half south to Atlanta where there are TV stations, and CNN, and TBS, and video editing classes, and accomplish his dream. As long as he first discovers the show cops, he should be fine.
什么样的人在被警察拦下时，决定去检查新车的后备箱？这是个糟糕的主意。但艺术家马特是位艺术家。他是《老友记》里的菲比。他没有意识到成功就在手边。他可以往南走一个半小时去亚特兰大，那里有电视台、CNN、TBS、视频剪辑课，他可以实现他的梦想。只要他先发现《警察》这个节目，他应该就没问题了。
Eugene Mirman.
尤金·米尔曼。
[MUSIC - "CRUISIN' IN THE ATL" BY OUTKAST]
[音乐 - OutKast的“Cruisin' in the ATL”]
Not far from Hall County is Pickens County. On April 9, 2006, a soldier from Pickens County serving in Iraq was killed by an IED. Specialist David Collins was 24. His body was flown to Atlanta in a convoy of patrol cars drove from Pickens County down to the Atlanta Airport about an hour and half way to meet the body and escort it back home to be buried.
离霍尔县不远是皮肯斯县。2006年4月9日，一名来自皮肯斯县、在伊拉克服役的士兵死于简易爆炸装置。大卫·柯林斯列兵才24岁。他的遗体被空运到亚特兰大，一个由巡逻车组成的车队从皮肯斯县开到亚特兰大机场，大约一个半小时路程，迎接遗体并护送回家埋葬。
At the time, Allen Wiggington was the Chief Deputy at the Pickens County Sheriff's Department. He was one of the escorts that day. And he was surprised when they got to the airport and they were told not to drive to some cargo area to retrieve the coffin, but to a commercial jet. It was parked right at the passenger gate.
当时，艾伦·威金顿是皮肯斯县治安官办公室的首席副治安官。他是那天护送人员之一。当他们到达机场时，他很惊讶，因为他们被告知不要去什么货运区领取灵柩，而是去一架商业客机。它就停在客运登机口。
When we pulled up to the plane, obviously I look up and there's people at the window in all the gates because they're five patrol cars with their blue lights on and a hearse. And the plane is sitting there The baggage compartment hasn't opened yet. All of use are just kind of standing there. And the cargo door to the plane opens.
当我们停在飞机旁时，我抬头看，登机口的所有窗口都有人在看，因为有五辆闪着蓝灯的巡逻车和一辆灵车。飞机就在那里。行李舱还没打开。我们所有人都站在那里。飞机的货舱门打开了。
It literally was chilling. Because the casket starts down the roller coming out of the airplane and coming down the conveyor belt, not lonely is everything on the ground around us stopped, literally the buses carrying the staff, everything has stopped. You look up in the windows and everybody has stopped. And there's kids watching. And the military escorts came over to where the casket was. And I'm still standing there watching. And it wasn't until they closed the door on the hearse that people start resuming kind of. You hear some activity. You hear some things. You look around and you realize that literally for just a minute, the world stood still at that airport while they took that boy's body off that airplane.
那场景真的让人不寒而栗。因为灵柩开始从飞机上滑下来，沿着传送带出来，不仅我们周围地面上的一切都停下了，运送员工的巴士、所有东西都停下了。你抬头看窗口，每个人都停下了。有孩子们在看。军事护送人员走到灵柩旁。我依然站在那儿看着。直到他们关上灵车门，人们才开始恢复活动。你听到了一些动静。你听到了一些声音。你环顾四周，意识到那一分钟里，那个机场的世界真的静止了，直到他们把那个男孩的遗体从飞机上取下来。
I was on a plane about six months after that. And I was flying in from Washington. I had been to Washington, D.C. for some event. And on the plane there was a soldier sitting there. And he sat there, red-headed pale kid, probably 18, 19 years old. He was coming home. And the flight attendant came in on their airline and said, ladies and gentlemen, I just wanted to offer you, we're fixing to pull up the gate. I know we're running a little bit late. We're trying to get you out of here. Some of you have connecting flights. But in the back of the plane there's a young man, Specialist so and so. And he is coming home for the first time. He's been in Iraq for eight and a half months. And he has a new baby daughter that'll be meeting him at the gate that he has never seen before. And I think I would probably beat somebody to death if they had got out of their seat and didn't let him get off that plane first.
那之后大约六个月，我在飞机上。我正从华盛顿飞回来。我去华盛顿特区参加某个活动。飞机上坐着一名士兵。他就坐在那儿，红头发，脸色苍白，大概18、19岁。他要回家了。空姐进来说：“女士们先生们，我只想告诉你们，我们要准备靠停登机口了。我知道我们有点晚点。我们尽量让你们尽快下机。有些人还要转机。但在机舱后部有一位年轻的小伙子，某某列兵。他第一次回家了。他在伊拉克待了八个半月。他有个刚出生的女儿要在登机口迎接他，他从来没见过面。我想如果有人起身不让他先下飞机，我可能会把那人揍个半死。”
Allen Wiggington, he's now a Magistrate Judge in Pickens County. According to the Department of Defense, as of this week, 140 Georgians have died in Iraq, 38 in Afghanistan.
艾伦·威金顿，他现在是皮肯斯县的裁判法官。据国防部称，截至本周，已有140名乔治亚人在伊拉克牺牲，38人在阿富汗牺牲。
Coming up, there's old timers taking up space at the Hardy's in Whitfield County, lingering over their coffee. What do they have to say for themselves? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，有老人们在惠特菲尔德县的哈迪餐厅里占着位置，喝着咖啡磨蹭。他们有什么要说的吗？芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目稍后继续，敬请收听。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, the Georgia Rambler in which we imitate an old newspaper column from the Atlanta Journal in the 1970s. Nine of us went to Georgia, each to a different county. We drove into small towns that we'd never been to before, walked up to people like the Georgia Rambler reporter used to do, and asked who was the most interesting, unforgettable, person in town, which led us to more stories than we could possibly fit into one hour.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目是“乔治亚漫游者”，我们模仿了20世纪70年代《亚特兰大新闻报》的一个老专栏。我们九个人去了乔治亚州，每人前往一个不同的县。我们开车走进从未去过的小镇，像“乔治亚漫游者”的记者过去那样走到人们面前，问谁是镇上最有趣、最难忘的人，这导致我们发现的故事比一小时节目能容纳的还要多。
We head now into Chattooga County. Lisa Pollak went there. Though her story begins in town called Dalton over in Whitfield County.
我们现在前往查图加县。丽莎·波拉克去了那里。虽然她的故事始于惠特菲尔德县一个叫道尔顿的镇。
For years, the newspaper in Dalton, Georgia ran a question on its front page every day, something like do you agree with the governor's budget cuts? Or what's your favorite Christmas meal? Readers called in and the paper printed their answers. The editor back then was a guy named Jimmy Espy. And one night Jimmy was so busy on deadline that he didn't have time to think of a new question. So instead, he just asked readers something like tell us what you think. That's right, tell the paper what you think anonymously about anything.
多年来，乔治亚州道尔顿的报纸每天都在头版刊登一个问题，比如你同意州长的预算削减吗？或者是你最喜欢的圣诞餐是什么？读者们打来电话，报纸把他们的回答印出来。当时的编辑是一个叫吉米·埃斯皮的人。有一天晚上，吉米在截稿前太忙了，没时间想新问题。所以他干脆问读者诸如“告诉我们你的想法”之类的问题。没错，匿名告诉报纸你对任何事情的想法。
The next day the paper got so many more calls than usual that Jimmy never went back to the old question format again. People had a lot to say, and they weren't shy about saying it. Within weeks, Jimmy told me, half the town was in a frenzy after one man called to complain that the old timers drinking coffee were taking up too much space at the [? Hardees on Saturday mornings.
第二天，报纸收到的电话比平时多得多，吉米就再也没有换回原来的提问模式了。人们有很多话要说，而且他们从不羞于表达。吉米告诉我，几周之内，全镇都陷入了疯狂，此前有人打电话抱怨说，那些喝咖啡的老头子们在[听不清]周六早上占用了太多空间。
The next thing you know the old timers are fired up, the wives and kids of the old timers are fired up. More people started calling in saying yeah, I'm tired of sitting in line all day waiting on my sausage biscuit. And it went on. It went on for a while.
紧接着你会发现老人们火了，老人们的妻子和孩子们也火了。更多人开始打电话说：是的，我厌倦了整天排队等我的香肠饼。事情就这样持续下去，持续了一段时间。
The old people called in too? And what did they say?
老人们也打电话进来？他们说了什么？
A lot of them kept bringing up World War II.
他们很多人不断提起二战。
Wait, how so?
等等，怎么提的？
You know, the kind of mentality of we beat Hitler. So you just sit down and wait on your sausage biscuit, kid. That really was the talk of town. And it seemed like about every two to three weeks something else would hit that would really fire up the imagination and you would get a lot of calls.
你知道，那种“我们打败了希特勒”的心态。所以你这个小家伙，就坐下等着你的香肠饼吧。这真的成了全镇的话题。看起来每隔两三周就会有别的东西出现，真正点燃人们的想象力，你就会接到很多电话。
About a year and a half later, Jimmy left the Dalton Paper and went to the Summerville News in Chattooga County. That's where I met him. Jimmy's family runs the Summerville News. His brother is one of the owners. His uncle is the editor and publisher. And even before Jimmy was hired, his relatives decided to borrow his idea from Dalton, and invited their readers to speak their minds in a column called Sound Off.
大约一年半后，吉米离开了道尔顿的报纸，去了查图加县的《萨默维尔新闻》。我就是在那里见到他的。吉米的家人经营着《萨默维尔新闻》。他哥哥是老板之一。他叔叔是编辑兼出版人。甚至在吉米被录用之前，他的亲戚们就决定借用他在道尔顿的想法，邀请读者在一个叫“鸣不平”的专栏里畅所欲言。
Now I think it's fair to say that in a lot of small, Southern towns, telling people what you really think out in public, in front of strangers, is not usually recommended. During my visit to Summerville, the people I interviewed were polite, they were gracious, full of pleasant observations. And then I open the Summerville News.
现在我认为可以公平地说，在许多南方小镇，在公开场合、当着陌生人的面说出你的真实想法，通常是不被推荐的。在我访问萨默维尔期间，我采访的人都很礼貌、亲切，充满了愉快的观察。然后我打开了《萨默维尔新闻》。
The music at the fireworks was pathetic.
烟花表演时的音乐太可怜了。
That's Jimmy reading a recent Sound Off.
这是吉米在读最近的一条“鸣不平”。
Only one song had something to do with patriotism. No wonder there so many drunks around the county. They should have played them Lee Greenwood, Independence, or the National Anthem.
只有一首歌与爱国主义有关。难怪县里有这么多醉鬼。他们应该放李·格林伍德的歌、独立曲或国歌。
I just read where if we get caught on our cell phone while driving, we get a ticket. Well what about our precious cops who are seen driving around town talking on cell phones and texting? Fair is fair.
我刚读到，如果我们在开车时被抓到玩手机，会被开罚单。那么我们那些宝贵的警察呢？他们被看见开着车在城里打手机、发短信。公平就是公平。
And one more.
再来一条。
I think those students voicing their opinions about the school board's cuts need to shut up. Let the adults handle the grownup decisions. And you teenagers stick with your computer games. That's a good one.
我认为那些对校董会的削减发表意见的学生需要闭嘴。让成年人处理成人的决定吧。你们这些青少年还是去玩电脑游戏吧。那是一条好评论。
The fast typist there in Jason Espy, Jimmy's cousin. He's wearing headphones and transcribing the latest batch of Sound Off calls.
那里的快速打字员是杰森·埃斯皮，吉米的表弟。他戴着耳机，正在录入最新一批“鸣不平”的来电。
That was a long one there. That lady was talking really fast.
那条很长。那位女士说得真快。
If Sound Off were a bar, Jason would be a bouncer. Every call, e-mail, and hand-written note, up to 100 submissions a week goes to him first. If a comment is libelous, unfair, or too racy, it's cut.
如果“鸣不平”是一个酒吧，杰森就是保镖。所有的电话、电子邮件和手写便条，每周多达100份的投稿首先都交给他。如果评论是诽谤性的、不公平的或太露骨的，就会被删掉。
I don't think I've announced it or anything. But these people out in the community know that it's me. And they'll say, "Hey Jason, you better print this one. Or I'm going to raise some sand if you don't print this one now".
我不认为我宣布过什么，但社区里的人都知道是我。他们会说：“嘿，杰森，你最好印这一条。不然如果你现在不印，我就要翻天了。”
He get's Sound Offs scribbled on napkins or slipped under the door. A few times people have even stopped him in public to dictate a Sound Off on the spot.
他收到的“鸣不平”是写在餐巾纸上的，或者是从门缝塞进来的。有几次人们甚至在公共场合拦住他，当场要求口述一条“鸣不平”。
Well, it's weird. I hate the Sound Off. But then again, I enjoy the Sound Off.
嗯，这很奇怪。我讨厌“鸣不平”。但话说回来，我喜欢“鸣不平”。
Wait, you hate the Sound Off?
等等，你讨厌“鸣不平”？
I really do. I hate the Sound Off. On one hand--
我真的讨厌。我讨厌“鸣不平”。一方面——
Jason told me the first problem he has with Sound Off is the anonymity. It bothers him that people can name names and throw stones, but never own up to it. And there's a second problem.
杰森告诉我，他对“鸣不平”的第一个不满是匿名性。让他困扰的是人们可以点名道姓地扔石头，却从不承担责任。还有第二个问题。
Here is this a great opportunity for people to address social issues and correct all these injustices, yet most of the time we use it to talk about Krystal hamburgers.
这是一个人们解决社会问题、纠正所有这些不公正的好机会，但大多数时候我们用它来谈论水晶汉堡。
Yes, Krystal hamburgers. That's Krystal with a K, the Southern fast food chain known for those square little burgers sold by the sack full. Think White Castle if you're a Yankee. There are 77 Krystal's in Georgia. And the fact that not one of them is located in Chattooga County has inspired many a Sound Off, counter Sound Off, and counter counter Sound Off, such as to Steve the owner of the local Mcdonald's franchise, have you considered starting at Krystal franchise? Why must I drive 20 minutes to get a Krystal with cheese? It's economic insanity to use $5 in gas for a $1 burger. In response to the person driving 20 minutes to get Krystal hamburger, why drive it if you're going to complain?
是的，水晶汉堡。那个带K的Krystal，以那种按袋卖的小方块汉堡闻名的南方快餐连锁店。如果你是北方人，可以参考白色城堡汉堡。乔治亚州有77家水晶汉堡店。事实上，查图加县一家都没有，这激发了许多“鸣不平”，反向“鸣不平”，以及反向反向“鸣不平”，比如：致当地麦当劳连锁店的老板史蒂夫，你考虑过开一家水晶汉堡特许经营店吗？为什么我必须开20分钟车去买一个带芝士的水晶汉堡？为了一个1美元的汉堡花5美元油费简直是经济疯子。回应那个开20分钟车去买水晶汉堡的人：如果你要抱怨，为什么要开那么久的车去买？
I didn't know that Krystal hamburgers were so important. In psychology it was that the Maslow's hierarchy of needs, Krystal hamburgers in the South is at the top of Maslow's hierarchy. And all else is below Krystal hamburgers. Well, I'll tell you what's  below Krystal hamburgers, is fried catfish and potholes. And what happens when people are driving over these potholes.
我不知道水晶汉堡竟然如此重要。在心理学上，马斯洛需求层次理论中，南方的水晶汉堡排在马斯洛需求层次的最顶端。其他的都在水晶汉堡之下。好吧，我告诉你什么在水晶汉堡之下，是炸鲶鱼和坑洞。当人们开着车经过这些坑洞时会发生什么。
I stuck around the office a bit while Jason transcribed calls.
在杰森录入电话时，我在办公室待了一会儿。
Here's one.
这是其中一条。
This is today, right?
这是今天的，对吧？
There's no telling here.
这可说不准。
Yes, I believe that Chattooga County should be behind our local [UNINTELLIGIBLE] that is on an environmental mission--
是的，我相信查图加县应该支持我们当地的[听不清]，他正在执行一项环保使命——
The gist of this woman's message was that county residents should fight pollution. They should protect local waterways.
这位女士留言的要点是，县居民应该与污染作斗争。他们应该保护当地的水道。
What do you think of that?
你觉得那怎么样？
I think I put her up to that?
我觉得是我让她这么说的？
What are you saying? What do you mean?
你是什么意思？你的意思是？
I put her up to that because I knew you were coming today. I said please call at 1:00 and talk about maybe some kind of environmental issue. And we won't seem so crazy.
是我让她这么说的，因为我知道你今天会来。我说请在1点打个电话，谈谈某种环保问题吧。这样我们看起来就不会显得那么疯狂。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Yeah, I'm serious.
是的，我是认真的。
Well, I admire that you're admitting that.
好吧，我佩服你的诚实。
Jason worries that outsiders were get a bad impression of where he lives reading Sound Off. But the impression I got, and I read quite a few of them, is simply that there's a lot of people who just really needed to say something, who got to say it, no interruption, no argument. What I liked about Sound Off, is that it feels like real life. Most days there's plenty to complain about. And every once in a while, people surprise you. This Sound Off ran July 8. I asked Jimmy to read it.
杰森担心局外人读了“鸣不平”后会对他住的地方有坏印象。但我得到的印象（我读了不少）很简单：这里有很多真的需要表达点什么的人，他们说出来了，没有打断，没有争吵。我喜欢“鸣不平”的地方是，它感觉像是真实的生活。大多数日子里，总有很多值得抱怨的事情。而偶尔，人们会让你感到惊喜。这条“鸣不平”出现在7月8日。我让吉米读了它。
"A local company closed its doors this past week. Unfortunately I was an employee that lost my job. I just want to thank Mike, Cathy, and Charlie for the chance to work for you since the year 2000. Thank you Jarrett family for not treating me only as an employee, but treating me as part of the family. I wish you all the luck in the future and wish all their former employees well." And that's somebody who just lost their jobs saying thanks to the people who had to let them go. I came to Summerville to find someone unforgettable. I don't know this man's name. But I won't forgot him.
“一家当地公司上周关门了。不幸的是，我是一名失业的员工。我只想感谢迈克、凯茜和查理从2000年以来给我的工作机会。感谢贾雷特一家没有仅仅把我当作雇员，而是把我当作家庭的一员对待。祝你们未来好运，也祝所有前员工一切顺利。”这就是一个刚刚失业的人感谢那些不得不辞退他们的人。我来萨默维尔是为了寻找一个难忘的人。我不知道这个人的名字。但我不会忘记他。
The next up is Jane Feltes. Jane is also the producer of today's show.
接下来是简·费尔特斯。简也是今天节目的制片人。
And Jane, you went to two different counties, counties that sit right next to each other.
简，你去了两个不同的县，两个彼此紧邻的县。
Yeah, Coffee and Bacon.
是的，咖啡县和培根县。
And they're named after the foods?
它们是以食物命名的吗？
No, actually they're named after people, John E. Coffee and Augustus Octavius Bacon.
不，其实它们是以人命名的，约翰·E·咖啡和奥古斯都·奥克塔维厄斯·培根。
Augustus Octavius Bacon is quite a name.
奥古斯都·奥克塔维厄斯·培根真是个响亮的名字。
And they're both in the military. And they were both senators.
而且他们都在军队服役。他们也都是参议员。
OK, well I'm learning a lot.
好吧，我学到了很多。
And they were both delicious.
而且他们都很美味。
Obviously so. So where do we start? What town?
显然如此。那么我们从哪儿开始？哪个镇？
I'm in Douglas, which is in Coffee County, at the busiest place I can find in town. And there's roughly around 11,000 people in Douglas. So I go to this place Flash Foods, which is a gas station slash convenience store. It's pretty busy on a Wednesday morning. And the clerk there, I noticed she's like talking to everybody. Her name is Tamika. So I ask her who the most interesting person in town is. She says her friend Karen Darby who works down at the other Flash Foods at the south side of town.
我在咖啡县的道格拉斯，在镇上我能找到的最忙的地方。道格拉斯大约有11000人。所以我去了那家叫“闪电食品”的地方，那是一家加油站兼便利店。周三早上那里很忙。收银员名叫塔米卡，我注意到她跟每个人都在聊天。所以我问她谁是镇上最有趣的人。她说她在镇南边另一家“闪电食品”工作的朋友卡伦·达比。
She always keeps me laughing. She just left [UNINTELLIGIBLE] as a matter of fact.
她总能让我发笑。事实上，她刚离开[听不清]。
All right, I'll go look for her. Thanks Tamika. I drive south, I'd say about a mile or two to the other Flash Foods and I find Karen. She tells me no, she's not the one. Who I need to talk to is Adam.
好吧，我去找她。谢谢塔米卡。我往南开了大约一两英里到另一家“闪电食品”，找到了卡伦。她告诉我，不，她不是那个人。我需要去和亚当谈谈。
Right over here is Adam. Let me show you.
那边就是亚当。让我带你看。
She directs me across the street to this white building that has a red sign and some guitars hanging in the window. Vickers Music. I ask for Adam.
她指引我过马路，来到那栋有一块红色招牌、窗户上挂着一些吉他的白色建筑——维克斯音乐店。我问找亚当。
Adam-- we got some animals in here-- who is the most interesting person in this store? Adam, she wants to interview you.
亚当——我们这儿有些动物——店里最有趣的人是谁？亚当，她想采访你。
Adam comes out of a room at the back of the store and makes his way through the stacks of amplifiers, keyboards, guitars hanging overhead. He's tall, bald, kind of looks like a softer Stone Cold Steve Austin. He quickly explains to me that this is his family's business. His folks and little brother can take over helping customers while we talk.
亚当从店后面的一间屋子里走出来，穿过成堆的音箱、键盘和悬挂在头顶的吉他，向我走来。他个子很高，秃头，看起来有点像柔和版的“冷石”史蒂夫·奥斯汀。他很快向我解释说，这是他家族的生意。我们可以聊天，他父母和弟弟可以帮忙招呼顾客。
We've been here 31 years.
我们在这里31年了。
Is is going well?
进展顺利吗？
Oh yeah, always, always. The music business is different from other businesses. When you have a down economy, we thrive.
哦，是的，一直很顺利。音乐行业跟其他行业不同。当你处于经济衰退期，我们反而会兴旺。
Really
真的吗？
Sure. People stay home. You sit on the front porch and you remember that you had a guitar. When you sit down and you strum a guitar, you forget I just got laid off from the job. I just had this happen or had that happen. My guitar sales pick up. My overall instrument sales pick up.
当然。人们待在家里。你坐在前廊，记起你还有一把吉他。当你坐下弹奏吉他时，你会忘记“我刚失业了”、“我刚发生了这事或那事”。我的吉他销量上升了。我的整体乐器销量都上升了。
How did you learn to play?
你是怎么学会弹奏的？
I learned to play with a Willie Nelson song book and a guitar. And I would site in my room at night and learn chords and strum right on my own.
我是用威利·纳尔逊的歌本和一把吉他自学的。我晚上会坐在房间里，自己学习和弦和弹奏。
Did your dad teach you how to read sheet music?
你爸爸教你识谱了吗？
No, he gave me a book. I told you it was hard. He gave you a book and said you want to play? There is is. Go learn.
没有，他给了我一本书。我跟你说了，这很难。他给了你一本书说，想弹？就在那儿。去学吧。
Strange seeing as how his dad owns a music store and used to tour the country in a band Adam says his dad just wasn't around that much.
考虑到他爸爸拥有音乐店，还曾在乐队里全国巡演，这很奇怪，亚当说他爸爸就是没怎么露面。
We were getting off the ground when I was young. We were just getting the business off the ground. So he was very, very consumed with the business. He was gone. He was working all the time from daylight to late at night. So I didn't see him a lot. But I mean, he made it work. I can come in now and have a business.
我年轻的时候，生意刚刚起步。我们只是在让生意起步。所以他非常、非常忙于生意。他不在。他总是从黎明工作到深夜。所以我没怎么见到他。但我的意思是，他让生意成功了。我现在能进来拥有一份事业。
Are you married?
你结婚了吗？
Yes.
是的。
And do you have any kids?
你有孩子吗？
I have one child. He is two.
我有一个孩子。他两岁了。
Are you going to try to push him into the family business?
你要强迫他继承家族生意吗？
No I'm not going to push him into nothing. I want him to do what he wants to do.
不，我什么都不会强迫他做的。我想让他做他想做的事。
You want to be a different kind of dad then your dad?
你想做一个和你爸爸不同的爸爸？
I already am.
我已经是了。
In what way?
哪方面？
I enjoy spending time with him. And not to say-- you understand that-- not to say that he didn't. But I am really hands on. We go fishing every evening.
我很享受和他在一起的时光。并不是说——你明白——并不是说他不享受。但我真的是亲力亲为。我们每天晚上都去钓鱼。
Every evening?
每天晚上？
Almost every evening if I can get home before dark. If I have a lot of work going on we go fishing. and then I have to put him to bed and get up and come back, that's what we do.
如果我能在天黑前到家，几乎每天晚上。如果我有大量工作要做，我们还是会去钓鱼。然后我必须哄他睡觉，再爬起来回来工作，这就是我们的生活。
Mind you, he's saying all of this within ear shot of his entire family, dad included.
请注意，他是在他全家人，包括他父亲都在听得到的地方说这些的。
Will you play a song for me?
你能为我弹一首歌吗？
Adam picks up his guitar and gives it a quick tuning.
亚当拿起吉他，快速调了调音。
Remember John Denver? This is a take off of his Country Roads.
记得约翰·丹佛吗？这是他的《乡村路》的改编版。
[GUITAR MUSIC  AND SINGING]
[吉他音乐和歌唱]
He's sitting a foot in front of me and staring directly in my eyes. I wasn't sure should I look away or is this what happens when you ask someone to sing you a song.
他就坐在我面前一英尺处，直视着我的眼睛。我不确定我该移开目光，还是这就是当你请求某人为你唱歌时会发生的事情。
[GUITAR MUSIC  AND SINGING]
[吉他音乐和歌唱]
We have a good time with that one.
我们唱那首玩得很开心。
Well next up, a county right in the middle of the state. And Sarah Koenig, you are the one who went there.
好吧，接下来，该州中部的县。莎拉·柯尼格，你是去那里的人。
Right. I was assigned Twiggs County. The county city is Jeffersonville, a city of about 1,500 people, majority African American, majority poor. There used to be a lot of mining jobs here. But now they're all gone. At just before 5 PM, I wandered into city hall. There's this very nice guy sitting behind the desk who said the most interesting person in town was his boss.
没错。我被分配到了特威格斯县。县治是杰斐逊维尔，一个约有1500人口的城市，多数是非裔美国人，多数是穷人。这里曾经有很多采矿工作。但现在全没了。下午5点前，我溜进市政厅。桌子后面坐着一位非常友善的男士，他说镇上最有趣的人是他的老板。
She's just full of life. She's been a lot of places.
她充满了活力。她去过很多地方。
Why, what is the story of her life, I mean broadly?
为什么，她的生活故事是什么，我是说大体上？
I'll let her tell it. I'm not going to spoil it for the people I'm serious.
我让她自己告诉你吧。我不想扫大家的兴，我是说真的。
And you're not just telling me this because she's your boss and you have to suggest you boss. (SUBJECT) CITY HALL EMPLOYEE: Well yeah, she is my boss, but that's not the reason I'm telling you this. I can tell you other things about her being my boss, but you wouldn't want to hear those.
你不是因为她是你的老板，不得不建议你的老板才这么说的吧？（市政厅员工）：好吧，是的，她是我的老板，但那不是我跟你说这个的原因。我还能告诉你其他关于她是我的老板的事，但你可能不想听。
I tracked her down. Her name is Sonya Mallory in a different county, actually, where she was working her other job at a cosmetology school, a pretty sad looking cosmetology school in a corner of a strip mall.
我找到了她。她的名字叫索尼娅·马洛里，其实是在另一个县，她正在那里做她的另一份工作，在一家美容学校，一家在购物中心角落里看起来挺惨的美容学校。
And I'm actually the director of the school.
其实我是学校的校长。
And how long have you been doing that?
你做这个多久了？
Well, I've been doing it for about six years. Actually and I applied for this job because I had a leak in my ceiling, and I was going to like do some extra work. But once I got here, I haven't fixed my roof yet.
嗯，大约六年了。其实申请这份工作是因为我天花板上有个漏点，我想做点额外工作。但一旦来到这儿，我到现在还没修好我的屋顶。
The reason she hasn't fixed her roof, is because once she realized what was going on with her students, a lot of single mothers, no money, she started pitching in. She and a couple of other teachers pulled their money to buy a year's worth of bus fares for a few students, plus gas money, lunch money. They even swapped clothes.
她没修屋顶的原因是，当她意识到她的学生们的情况——很多单身母亲，没钱——她开始伸出援手。她和其他几位老师自掏腰包，为几个学生买了一整年的公交车费，还有油费、午餐费。她们甚至交换衣服穿。
Because you can't afford it at the Salvation Army if you're really poor.
因为如果你真的很穷，你甚至在救世军那儿也买不起。
It's not so much that Sonya Mallory is a bleeding Heart It's that stuff like this drives her crazy, seeing black people struggling, no one helping her out. Plus she's been there, which leads us to her other job, the one back in Jeffersonville.
这并不是说索尼娅·马洛里是个“滥好人”。只是像这样的事情让她抓狂，看到黑人们挣扎，没人伸出援手。加上她曾经也经历过，这把我们引向了她的另一份工作，回到杰斐逊维尔的那份工作。
But before I get to that, some background. Sonya Mallory is 56. She was born in Jeffersonville, grew up in a tiny rented house, three rooms, seven kids in bunk beds. Her dad worked on the railroad, which was a good job, but he was a terrible alcoholic. And when he'd come home at the end of the week he terrorized the house beating up their mom, chasing the kids with a shotgun. The cops never did anything about it. Sonya hated him.
但在我谈到那一点之前，先补充点背景。索尼娅·马洛里56岁。她在杰斐逊维尔出生，长在一间租来的小房子里，三间屋子，七个孩子睡在双层床上。她爸爸在铁路工作，那是个好工作，但他是个极其酗酒的人。当他周五晚上回家时，他会恐吓全家，殴打妈妈，拿着猎枪追赶孩子们。警察从来没对此做过什么。索尼娅恨他。
Her mother worked for a white family, taking care of their kids and cooking. One day when Sonya and her little brother were walking home from school, a car came along, swerved, and hit her brother, broke his arm and his leg. And it turned out the driver was one of the white kids her mother took care of. And the white family, they never even came to check in on her brother to see how he was doing.
她的母亲为一个白人家庭工作，照顾他们的孩子并做饭。有一天，当索尼娅和她弟弟放学回家时，一辆车冲过来，横冲直撞，撞倒了她弟弟，折断了他的胳膊和腿。结果司机竟然是她母亲照顾的白人孩子之一。而那个白人家庭，他们甚至从没来看望过她弟弟，看看他怎么样了。
And I thought that was the most terrible thing. Here it is my momma seeing about their kids. And one of their kids run over my brother and you don't see them anywhere. So I mean, that was a bunch of hokey.
我觉得那是世上最可怕的事。这就是我妈妈照顾他们的孩子。他们的孩子撞倒了我弟弟，你却连个人影都见不到。所以，那简直是一派胡言。
Was everybody noticing these things? Or would you sort of madder about these things than people around you? Do you what I mean? Somehow you just feel like wait, why is nobody else mad about this? Or was everybody mad about it?
大家有没有注意到这些事？还是说你比周围的人对这些事更愤怒？你知道我的意思吗？为什么你会觉得“等等，为什么别人对这事不生气？”还是说每个人都很生气？
No, everybody wasn't. That's why I found it totally amazing. Like nobody else was. Because my mama still went to work for them. As a matter of fact, I think I was mad at her for a while.
不，并不是每个人。这就是我觉得不可思议的地方。好像没人觉得有问题。因为我妈妈依然去为他们工作。事实上，我想我有一段时间甚至恨过她。
After Sonya graduated high school, her first order of business was to get away from Jeffersonville. She moved to Macon, joined the military, worked as an army nurse, then at a VA hospital, and finally moved back to Jeffersonville in the late 1980s and looked around.
索尼娅高中毕业后的第一要务就是逃离杰斐逊维尔。她搬到了梅肯，参了军，做了一名陆军护士，然后在退伍军人医院工作，最后在20世纪80年代末搬回了杰斐逊维尔，环顾四周。
When I came home I realized Jesus Christ, Jeffersonville is the same as it was when I left. There was nothing there. There was no job for the ones that were staying. And there was nothing for the kids. They would just sit around on the streets. There was nothing.
当我回家时，我意识到，老天，杰斐逊维尔和我离开时一模一样。那里什么都没有。留下来的人没有工作。孩子也没什么去处。他们只是在街上游荡。什么都没有。
It made her mad. It made her think about all the unfairness she'd seen growing up. And one day she got an idea.
这让她很生气。这让她想起了她成长过程中看到的所有不公。有一天，她有个主意。
I had gone to the post office, and the guy there was on counsel, he was saying something about a lot of people having their water cut off. And of course he didn't know I was in there. And he said they cut a lot of black folks water off.
我去了邮局，那里的一个人是议员，他说了一些关于很多人被断水的事。当然他不知道我在那儿。他说他们切断了很多黑人的水。
Sonya said she knew some white folks who hadn't pay their bills either. Their water wasn't getting cut off.
索尼娅说她认识一些没付账单的白人。他们的水可没被切断。
And I said to myself, the post office is still in the same place. Everything's doing the same. Roads are bad. I mean you know, people aren't getting any help. So I said, you know what, I'm going to find out when the next election. And I found out when it was and I just ran for mayor.
我自言自语，邮局还在同一个地方。一切还是老样子。路况很差。我的意思是，你知道，人们得不到任何帮助。所以我说，你知道吗，我要看看下一次选举是什么时候。我查到了时间，就直接竞选市长了。
So Sonya Mallory decides to run for mayor in town that's never had a black mayor, never mind a black woman mayor. Everyone she talked to about it, her friends, her family, they'd all say the same thing.
于是索尼娅·马洛里决定在这样一个从未有过黑人市长的镇上竞选市长，更别说黑人女性市长了。她接触过的每个人，她的朋友，她的家人，他们都说同样的话。
It's not going to happen. They'd say, girl you know the people ain't going to let you do that. Because they've been in Georgia all these years. They ain't going to let you do that.
那是不可能的。他们会说：“姑娘，你知道人们不会让你那么做的。因为他们世世代代都在乔治亚州。他们不会让你那么做的。”
In that first election in 1991, they didn't let her do it. She lost by 13 votes to a white guy. Sonya told me black people on the voter rolls were turned away from the polls when white people who didn't even reside in the city were given ballots. And before you think yeah, but the loser always claims voter fraud, in the end a Georgia Superior Court Judge agreed with her and threw out the election results. And the Department of Justice sent four federal observers to monitor the do-over election eight months later.
在1991年的那第一次选举中，他们确实没让她赢。她以13票之差输给了一个白人。索尼娅告诉我，选民名单上的黑人被拒之门外，而那些根本不住在这个城市的白人却拿到了选票。在你觉得“是啊，但输家总会声称选民欺诈”之前，乔治亚州高等法院的一名法官最终同意了她的看法，并宣布选举结果无效。司法部派出了四名联邦观察员监督八个月后的重选。
But by that time, one of Sonya's sisters was dying of cancer. She was distracted and out of steam. She lost. Then tried again. And finally in 1999 she won. She was Mayor Sonya Mallory. Now she just had to figure out what that actually meant.
但在那时，索尼娅的一个姐妹因癌症去世了。她心力交瘁，失去了动力。她输了。然后又试了一次。最后在1999年，她赢了。她成了索尼娅·马洛里市长。现在她必须弄清楚这到底意味着什么。
I had no clue, no clue to what the whole big picture entailed. And I had never been there. There was nobody there to pass anything on to let me know what was actually going on.
我毫无头绪，对于整个全局包含的内容一无所知。我从没经历过。没人能传授我任何东西，让我知道实际发生了什么。
There's no process where the previous mayor says here's where we are.
没有前任市长说“这就是我们的状况”之类的流程吗？
Well there should be but naturally--
嗯，应该有，但很自然地——
With essentially no information about how to be mayor, she turned to the only available source, the record.
在对如何当市长几乎一无所知的情况下，她转向了唯一可用的资源——记录。
So I had to read the minutes from 1801 up until the time. So my brain is kind of--
所以我不得不阅读从1801年以来的会议记录，直到那个时间。所以我脑子有点——
Wait, you had to read 200 years of minutes.
等等，你必须阅读200年的会议记录？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
It took her most of a year to get through the minutes. Meanwhile she got threatening letters, her gossip about how people were saying she wouldn't last. To top it off, her husband got arrested for DUI and some other stuff, spent a year in jail. So her only source of income was her mayor's salary, $250 a month. So there she was, the mayor, sitting at home at night, no water, no lights. And the actual mayor job was turning out to be harder than she anticipated, especially the city council meetings. That part of the job, even ten years later, hasn't been highly productive. There's constant drama.
她花了一年时间才读完。同时，她收到了恐吓信，还有关于人们说她做不长的流言蜚语。最糟糕的是，她丈夫因为酒驾和其他事被捕，在监狱里待了一年。所以她唯一的收入来源就是市长薪水，每月250美元。所以她就在那里，市长，晚上坐在家里，没水，没灯。而且市长的工作证明比她预期的还要难，特别是市议会会议。那部分工作，即使十年后，也没有太大的成效。戏剧性事件不断发生。
Naturally, their thing was to fight against anything I say. Right now it's totally amazing. Because I can tell you when I first got in was all of my council people were Caucasians. No they're all black. But I can tell you this, there's no difference. Be careful what you ask for.
很自然地，他们的事就是反对我说的一切。现在这太神奇了。因为我可以告诉你，我刚上任时，我所有的议会成员都是白人。现在他们全都是黑人。但我可以告诉你，没什么区别。当你要求什么时要小心。
What? Like what's an example? What do they do?
什么？比如有什么例子？他们做什么？
They think their general job is to make sure employees ain't trying to cheat for five minutes and the police department, they're locking up their cousins. And they worry more about employees taking five minutes more of break than they do sitting there trying to get grant money to get something for the kids.
他们认为他们的日常工作就是确保雇员没在偷懒五分钟，警察部门在关押他们的亲戚。他们担心雇员多休息五分钟，远甚于坐在那里努力争取资金为孩子们换点东西。
I told them that one tie. Quit fighting against what we need to be doing that's important for the community. If you didn't have enough balls to run for mayor, I've got a couple left and I'll let you have them.
我曾那样告诉过他们。停止反对我们应该做的对社区重要的事情。如果你没有足够的胆量竞选市长，我还剩两颗，我可以借给你。
Council members I spoke to admitted the meetings can get kind of twisted up. But they say Mayor Mallory isn't exactly perfect either. They said she doesn't keep them informed, takes things into her own hands when she should be consulting them, doesn't follow protocol, or unfairly blames them for things.
我采访的议会议员承认会议有时会变得有点扭曲。但他们说马洛里市长自己也不完全完美。他们说她不让他们知情，在应该咨询他们时自行其是，不遵守协议，或者不公平地把事情归咎于他们。
The dysfunction is well known in town and beyond. It was especially bad in the beginning. Here's the lead of a 2001 Macon Telegraph story, "The Tuesday night meeting of the Jeffersonville City Council lasted either 15 minutes or one and a half hours depending on whom you ask.
这种功能障碍在镇内外广为人知。在刚开始时尤其严重。这是一篇2001年《梅肯电讯报》文章的开头：“周二晚上的杰斐逊维尔市议会会议持续了15分钟或一个半小时，这取决于你问谁。”
The U.S. Department of Agriculture suspended the city's grant application for a $7 million water and sewer expansions-- the city has had terrible sewage problems-- citing articles in the local paper that described malfeasance, sexism, and racism within the government. The report for the local paper and Twiggs told me the city council meetings were so ridiculous, she stopped covering them.
美国农业部暂停了该市申请的一项700万美元的供水和污水处理扩张计划——该市一直有严重的污水问题——理由是当地报纸描述政府内存在渎职、性别歧视和种族歧视的文章。特威格斯当地报纸的报道者告诉我，市议会会议太荒谬了，她不再报道它们了。
In her ten years as mayor, Sonya hasn't brought an airport, or a convention center, or a mall to the county, all early ambitions. But she's at least put computers in city , gotten grants to beautify the streets, dealt with recurring sewage problems. And then there are successes that are harder to quantify.
在担任市长的十年里，索尼娅没有为这个县带来机场、会议中心或购物中心，那都是早期的抱负。但她至少在市政厅安装了电脑，拿到了美化街道的拨款，处理了反复出现的污水问题。还有一些难以量化的成功。
Just little bitty minor things like black people would come to city hall and they were scared to come any further than the window.
只是一些微小的琐事，比如黑人们来到市政厅，但他们害怕超过那个窗口。
Which window?
哪个窗口？
The window where you pay the bill. Trust me. And I would say come on back. They'd be like, "nuh uh." You understand what I'm saying?
你付账单的那个窗口。相信我。我会说过来吧。他们会说：“不啊。”你明白我的意思吗？
Sonya says as the country has changed, things have gotten better in Jeffersonville. You can overhear blacks and whites chatting about the weather in the post office where there used to be silence between them. And you can see blacks working in the courthouse and the supermarket. Sonya says these steps might be small, but they add up.
索尼娅说，随着国家的变化，杰斐逊维尔的情况有所好转。你可以在邮局听到黑人和白人在聊天谈论天气，以前他们之间总是沉默。你可以看到黑人在法院和超市工作。索尼娅说这些步伐可能很小，但累积起来很重要。
Well we started our program today with Charles Salter, the newspaper reporter who was the original Georgia Rambler back in the 1970s. And we end our show with Charles Salter, his son, who everybody calls Chuck. For today's show, he went to Elbert County on the coast. But he also looked back at a huge stack of his dad's old stories.
好吧，我们今天以查尔斯·索尔特开始我们的节目，他是20世纪70年代“乔治亚漫游者”专栏的原创报纸记者。我们以他的儿子查尔斯·索尔特结束我们的节目，大家都叫他查克。为了今天的节目，他去了海边的埃尔伯特县。但他同时也回顾了他父亲的一大堆旧故事。
I was 11 years old when my dad became the Georgia Rambler. I don't remember him telling us about his new job. What I remember is that he now had a company car, not an anonymous sedan, but a big white whale of a station wagon with his name plastered on both sides, Charles Salter, the Georgia Rambler. The paper's name appears on the station wagon too, along with its motto, "Covers Dixie Like the Dew". That's dew as in morning dew. My dad was fond of reciting this line out loud like a favorite verse of poetry.
我11岁时，父亲成了“乔治亚漫游者”。我不记得他告诉过我们他的新工作。我记得的是他现在有了一辆公司用车，不是那种普通的轿车，而是一辆大白鲸般的旅行车，两边都贴着他的名字：查尔斯·索尔特，“乔治亚漫游者”。报纸的名字也出现在旅行车上，连同它的座右铭：“像晨露一样覆盖迪克西”。那是晨露的意思。我父亲喜欢大声背诵这一行，就像一段最喜欢的诗歌。
Because my name is also Charles Salter, the genius of this whole marketing ploy, a four-wheeled billboard crisscrossing the state was completely lost on me. Instead, the car was a kick me sign. I was in junior high school. On the days my dad picked me up from school or baseball practice, I begged him to take my mom's car, or at least park around the corner.
因为我的名字也叫查尔斯·索尔特，这个天才营销噱头——一辆四轮广告牌横穿全州——我完全没意识到。相反，这辆车就是个“踢我”标志。我在上初中。父亲接我放学或练习棒球的日子里，我求他开我妈妈的车，或者至少停在拐角处。
I rarely read my dad's column. At dinner he'd say, "I met a real character today". And mention some town I'd never heard of. I was indifferent. Everyone's father had a job, big deal.
我很少读父亲的专栏。吃晚饭时他说：“我今天遇到了一个真正的人物。”然后提到一个我从没听过的小镇。我无动于衷。每个人的父亲都有份工作，大不了多少。
Somewhere around 1976 or '77 during summer vacation, my dad got the idea that I should ramble along with him. So I climbed in that station wagon and we headed to some dot of a town on the map. To me, the countryside looked like one never-any crop. I couldn't tell where one farm ended and the next again.
大约在1976或77年的暑假，父亲有个主意，让我陪他一起漫游。所以我爬进那辆旅行车，我们朝着地图上的某个小圆点出发了。对我来说，乡村看起来像是一片永无止境的庄稼。我分不清农场哪里结束，另一家在哪里开始。
One day, we met a farmer name J. B. Lloyd. We sat on the back porch and my dad asked J. B. about farming without a tractor, just a horse and plow. I didn't ask any questions. I was shy. And about the only thing I wanted to know is do you have a TV out here? How do you watch Braves games or Charlie's Angels?
有一天，我们遇到了一位名叫J·B·劳埃德的农民。我们坐在后廊，父亲问J·B关于不用拖拉机、只靠马和犁耕作的事。我没问任何问题。我很害羞。我唯一想知道的是：你这儿有电视吗？你怎么看勇士队的比赛或《查理的天使》？
Reporting in small towns brought out another side of my dad. His southern accent got noticeably stronger. And he sounded like he'd flea Atlanta any minute. "Now I live in the city, but I'm not from there", he'd say to people. "I was born in Ocilla and grew up in Waycroft". He'd go on and on about his love of fishing on small ponds, and red eyed gravy and fried okra. He was shameless about this country cred. I, on the other hand, was a suburban kid. I thought fishing was boring. I preferred hanging out at the mall. In a way, going with my father on all those Georgia Rambler trips, it made me realize how different he and I were.
在小镇报道显露了父亲的另一面。他的南方口音明显变重了。他听起来随时会逃离亚特兰大。“我现在住城里，但我不是那儿人，”他会对人们说，“我出生在奥西拉，长在韦克罗夫特。”他会喋喋不休地谈论他喜欢在小池塘钓鱼、红眼肉汁和炸秋葵。他丝毫不以此为耻。相比之下，我是一个郊区孩子。我觉得钓鱼很无聊。我更喜欢在商场闲逛。在某种程度上，跟父亲一起去所有那些“乔治亚漫游者”的旅行，让我意识到他和我是多么不同。
For the show, I had my dad send me a box of old columns. As I read them after all these years, I found myself wondering what happened to the people who he wrote about. So I called a few. The college senior who moved into the woods to live without electricity and plumbing now lives in Alaska. The small town narcotics officer who worried she wouldn't find a husband who would put up with her job stayed on the force for 31 years and is happily married. And the two farmers who tried to stop the government from putting their farm underwater when it dammed to Savannah River, I found them too.
为了这个节目，我让父亲给我寄了一箱旧专栏。多年后读到它们时，我发现自己想知道他写过的人们后来怎么样了。所以我打了一些电话。那个搬进树林里生活、没电没管道的大学四年级学生现在住在阿拉斯加。那个担心找不到能忍受她工作丈夫的小镇缉毒警察在职31年，结婚生活幸福。还有那两个试图阻止政府在拦河筑坝萨凡纳河时淹没农场的农民，我也找到了他们。
All right, so I wanted to show you. Do you recognize this? Fight [UNINTELLIGIBLE], This is the story that my dad did? Do you remember my dad?
好的，所以我想给你看。你认得这个吗？战斗[听不清]，这是我父亲做的故事？你记得我父亲吗？
want to place him. I'm sorry I don't remember him. But it's been 33 years ago, you know. But we had you had so many people locked him channel four channels dirt train oh and turn over dogs
我想认出他。抱歉，我不记得他了。但那是33年前的事了，你知道。但我们……你有很多人……[听不清]……
Windell Cleveland with 36 when my dad interviewed him. He's 69 now. The story was about him and his father [? Cade ?] Cleveland. The Army Corps of Engineers came into Elbert County wanting to dam the Savannah River and create a 26,000-acre lake by flooding all the land in a river valley. The Cleveland's farm was right on the river, right in the path of the lake.
温德尔·克利夫兰在父亲采访他时36岁。他现在69岁。故事是关于他和他的父亲[凯德？]克利夫兰。陆军工程兵团来到埃尔伯特县，想在萨凡纳河筑坝，通过淹没河谷所有的土地来创造一个26000英亩的湖泊。克利夫兰一家的农场就在河边，就在湖的路径上。
They watched their neighbors sell one by one, and told they were the only ones left. They held out so long that Windell took to wearing a gun afraid federal marshals would show up and drag them off their property. They held out so long that finally the Army Corps did something kind of remarkable. After years of insisting they needed all of the Cleveland's land, the Corps buckled and offered Windell a deal to keep 36 acres.
他们看着邻居们一个接一个地卖掉农场，直到他们成了剩下的人。他们坚持太久了，温德尔开始戴着枪，害怕联邦警长会出现把他们从房产上拖走。他们坚持太久了，最后陆军工程兵团做了一件相当了不起的事。在坚持需要克利夫兰家所有土地多年后，兵团屈服了，并给了温德尔一个保留36英亩土地的交易。
I think I went down there and signed them, and then they moved in there that afternoon about 1 o'clock. We went down there and watched them cross. They come from [? Van's Creek ?] through yonder through the park. And they had 35 bulldozers
我想我下去签了字，那天下午1点他们就搬进去了。我们下去看着他们过河。他们从[范溪？]那边穿过公园。他们有35台推土机。
Windell's father [? Cade ?] died two years before this. So from the front of his house, Windell stood alone watching the bulldozers come over the horizon knocking down forests, leveling a the field of wheat, and toppling the old chimney. It was all that was left of the farmhouse built in 1741, the one his father was born in.
温德尔的父亲[凯德？]在这之前两年去世了。所以从他家的前门看，温德尔独自站在那里，看着推土机从地平线上开过来，撞倒森林，夷平麦田，推倒了旧烟囱。那是1741年建造的农舍仅存的一切，他父亲出生的地方。
They come in just like a gang of ants. Now it wasn't easy to watch none of it. You were like more or less giving your whole life away. It was just destroyed.
他们进来就像一群蚂蚁。这太难看了。你几乎是放弃了你的一生。它就这样被摧毁了。
When you build a dam that makes a lake, the water doesn't rush in all at once. Windell watched for a year as the water came closer drowning the farm acre by acre. When the lake was full, the water was almost all the way to windows house. On a map, his land looks like a leaf in a big puddle. He and his wife Charlene are surrounded by water on three sides.
当你筑坝建湖时，水不是一下子涌入的。温德尔看了一年，水越来越近，一英亩一英亩地淹没了农场。湖满时，水几乎到了温德尔的房子。在地图上，他的土地看起来就像大水坑里的一片叶子。他和妻子夏琳被水三面包围。
When I went to see him, Windell took me down to the lake. You can see it from his front porch. We walked through a field down a little wooden hill. It took two minutes tops.
我去见他时，温德尔带我到了湖边。你可以从他的前廊看到。我们穿过一片田野，走下一座小木丘。顶多用了两分钟。
How deep is this water that we're looking out? [INTERPOSING VOICES]
我们正在看的这片水有多深？
This is probably somewhere in the neighborhood of 75, 80 feet. You get on down and it's 85 somewhere. And you get on down 100 feet in a different location.
这大概在75、80英尺左右。你再往下走，某个地方有85英尺。在不同的地点，你往下走能有100英尺。
The strange thing about the lake is that the government put a 300 foot buffer between any developments in the water. So the shoreline looks pristine. There are no gaudy mansions, no big docks. It looks completely untouched like this is the way it always was.
湖最奇怪的事情是政府在任何开发项目和水之间划了300英尺的缓冲区。所以海岸线看起来原始。没有炫耀的豪宅，没有大码头。看起来完全未被触碰，就像它一直如此。
I feel guilty saying this, but it's a beautiful lake.
我说这话感到愧疚，但它是个美丽的湖。
Oh yes. It's pretty.
哦，是的。它很美。
The biggest irony in all of this is Windell fought this. He'll tell you it destroyed his way of life. But it's also made him a wealthy man. As the land became less valuable to Windell, it's become incredibly valuable to everybody else. His little patch of property is now prime lakefront real estate. Windell's land is worth more than $600,000 according to the county taxes assessor.
所有这一切中最大的讽刺是温德尔曾为之奋斗。他会告诉你这毁了他的生活方式。但也让他成了富人。随着土地对温德尔的价值下降，对其他人却变得极其有价值。根据县税务评估员的数据，他这一小块地现在是优质的湖畔房地产。温德尔的土地价值超过60万美元。
All around Windell, developers are putting in big, expensive homes and planning gated communities. Recently a guy in California called Windell and said I want your land. Just name your price. But the Windell, it doesn't make any sense that anyone thinks this land is worth so much. All he knows is that he's on land he can't farm. There's no room for crops. At best, he says, he can keeps four cows.
温德尔周围，开发商正在修建巨大的、昂贵的住宅，并规划封闭式社区。最近加州的一个人打电话给温德尔说：我要你的土地。只要说个价。但对温德尔来说，谁觉得这片土地价值这么高，根本没有道理。他只知道他住在这片他无法耕种的土地上。没地方种庄稼。他最好的说法是，他能养四头牛。
This land has got no value. I have nothing but red river, hills left. There's really no value. It used to wouldn't been worth nothing. The bottom land and the fields all down below where the covered is what was worth to me.
这片土地毫无价值。我只剩下红色的河流和丘陵了。真的毫无价值。以前它根本一文不值。底层的土地和田野，都在下面，那里曾是我看重的价值所在。
I ask him why he doesn't just sell this land and buy a real farm somewhere else for him and his son. $600,000, he could have his pick. Nobody understands, he says. Leaving this place would be like deserting his past, his parents and grandparents, the farm he took over when he was just 14 because his father was sick with cancer.
我问他为什么不直接卖掉这片土地，在其他地方给他和儿子买个真正的农场。60万美元，他可以随便挑。没人明白，他说。离开这里就像抛弃了他的过去，他的父母和祖父母，以及他14岁时因为父亲患癌而接手的农场。
Windell still has all the old farm equipment, even though we has no use for most of it. Everything is in its place as if the fields might come back tomorrow and Windell would be ready. About 100 yards from the house that Windell lived in is his parents old house. Walking through it, you'd have no idea that they'd both been dead for more than 30 years. There's his dad's cigarettes tin, a drawer full of knives that his grandfather used to slaughter hogs, furniture dating back to the 1800s, two antique organs, his parents bed.
温德尔依然有所有旧农具，尽管他几乎用不着。一切都在原位，仿佛田野可能明天就会回来，而温德尔会准备好。离温德尔居住的房子约100码处是他父母的老房子。走过它，你根本不知道他们已经去世超过30年了。那里有他父亲的香烟盒，满满一抽屉祖父用来宰猪的刀，追溯到1800年代的家具，两架古董管风琴，他父母的床。
This is my mom's favorite chair. And that's her clothes she had in there. It's been in there ever since we lost her. December 18, 1968, that's when we lost her. They've been hanging there ever since. And they're still in good shape.
这是我妈最喜欢的椅子。那是她在那儿的衣服。自从失去她后就一直挂在那儿。1968年12月18日，那是我们失去她的日子。它们从那时起就一直挂在那里。它们依然保存完好。
And why do you hang onto it?
你为什么留着它？
I just love it. I just love knowing her clothes are in it, her dresses and everything.
我就是喜欢。我喜欢知道她的衣服还在那儿，她的连衣裙和一切。
These days even though the farm is gone, Windell can still stand on the hill in front of his house with me, and he can point to everything that used to be, where his grandparents lived, where his father was born, and where his father used to take his Model A car across the Savannah River on this ferry to court his mother. Every time he points though, he's pointing at the lake.
这些日子，尽管农场没了，温德尔依然可以和我一起站在房前的小山坡上，他可以指出曾经的一切：祖父母住的地方，他父亲出生的地方，以及他父亲曾带着他的福特A型车过萨凡纳河去向他母亲求爱的地方。不过他每次指出时，指的都是湖面。
You see where I tell you my uncle lived, that ridge run way on down there probably--
你看我告诉你我叔叔住的那儿，那道山脊一直延伸下去，大概——
So today, Windell's living on his daddy's farm, and in the way, I'm doing the same. All those times my dad took me out on his Georgia Rambler trips, I remember being 13 or 14 and meeting some stranger with my dad, being invited into the living room and listening as they opened up and told him some story. I remember how amazing it was that one minute we didn't know this person, and then the next we were hearing all these things about their life that they probably didn't tell many people at all.
所以今天，温德尔住在他父亲的农场上，而在某种意义上，我也在做同样的事。所有那些父亲带我参加“乔治亚漫游者”旅行的日子，我记得自己13或14岁，和父亲见到某个陌生人，被邀请进客厅，听着他们敞开心扉，告诉他一些故事。我记得我们前一分钟还不认识这个人，后一分钟就在听他们生活中那些很可能没告诉过多少人的事情，这有多神奇。
I know my dad took me on those trips to show me small town life, where he grew up, where my family was from. But what I took from them was a lesson he never intended, I decided to become a reporter. I write for magazines. I've written for newspapers, just like my dad. That's where I live now.
我知道父亲带我参加那些旅行是为了展示我小镇生活，他长大的地方，我家人的出身。但我从中学到了一课，他从未打算教：我决定成为一名记者。我为杂志写作。我为报纸写作，就像我的父亲一样。那就是我现在的归宿。
[MUSIC - "GEORGIA" BY CEE LO GREEN]
[音乐 - Cee Lo Green的“Georgia”]
Our program was produce today by Jane Feltes and me with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Johnathon Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Nancy Updike, senior producer Julie Snyder, Seth Lind is our production manager Emily Condon is our office manager, production help from Sean Wenn.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔洪、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、南希·厄普代克参与，高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德，塞思·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理，肖恩·温提供制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Dave Kestenbaum, who you heard tracking down FDR's Georgia history can be heard with his Planet Money colleagues on their twice-weekly podcast in co-production with our show, www.npr.org/money. Our website is thisamericanlife.org. You can sign up for our free weekly podcast. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for a program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia who remembers the time, it was a while back, when his wife took him to this private swimming pool with Frank Gorshen and Jack Nicholson.
戴夫·克斯坦鲍姆，你刚才听到他在追踪FDR在乔治亚州的历史，可以在我们的联合制作、每周两次的播客上听到他和《星球经济》的同事们的节目，www.npr.org/money。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。你可以注册我们免费的每周播客。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他还记得很久以前，他妻子带他去那个有弗兰克·戈申和杰克·尼科尔森的私人游泳池的时候。
And I look, and like right in my face she's got them jokers just strung out there.
我转过身。而且，她就在我面前……
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories on This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带更多故事回归《美国生活》。
[MUSIC - "GEORGIA" BY CEE LO GREEN]
[音乐 - Cee Lo Green的“Georgia”]
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI 国际公共广播电台。